alors ils jouent contre eux ni quoi on
va suivre
à mon avis ça devrait pas être très
compliqué comme match on
la différence de niveau est trop
important doit aller je vais à matt
l'échiquier
seule bande
le cadre est
ça commence à 21h normalement voir ce
que ça donne
si tu perds deux chambres a contraint
trois mois en fait je les récupère pas
dernièrement en fait j'ai jamais j'ai
pas récupéré de points depuis longtemps
lorsque je vois des gars qui m'ont
battue qui se sont fait ban ça fait
m'attendre mais ça devrait passer un nom
mais nico elle est vraiment pas très
forte c'est quoi son pseudo
c'est quoi son pseudo c'est nico
chaises comme hockey a les ailes et a
invoqué à les 560 en blitz les gars y'a
juste aucun risque il ya juste
réellement aucun risque et gars 560 en
blitz
non mais vraiment enfin je sais pas mais
même en cette battle on joue mieux
560 un blitz non mais je sais pas assez
sévères
y a rien à dire en fait c'est même plus
d échec à un moment donné quand j'en
sais rien c'est spécial 560 tu rates les
matins d'un an mais vous allez voir ça
va être spectaculaire
non mais c'est pas possible de perdre en
fait impossible
vous n'imaginez même pas en fait 560
android c'est terrible mais je vais
mourir dans une autre fenêtre mais vous
n'imaginez même pas en fait
cinq cent soixante ans beats et attendez
j'ai un bug sur chaise comme pour
poursuivre les partis c'est
impressionnant
mince c'est pas grave quand la game va
partir je pourrais la suite vu j'aurais
pas le follow du coup je vais mettre sur
la chaîne officielle pour être sûr
sentant blitz et ça existe juste pas en
fait
on va voir comment ça quand ça démarre
vous n'imaginez même pas trahi peut
faire la grève non mais là tu peux tout
faire là ce niveau là l'atout marche les
gars là absolument tout marche là tu
peux faire une grob tu peux tu peux
faire ce que tu veux la jouer un coup
suffit
la partie est là
et partie caisse et 800 828 ans donc
c'est un match aller retour
enfin déjà
on va avoir des choses assez
spectaculaire b6 alors déjà je peux vous
dire que j'avais vu sa prépa sa prépa
c'était cavalli m6 des six g6 et j'avais
dit à sartre ça sert même à rien de
regarder parce que c'est terrible
3 il fait doux
et au dessus
non mais vous avez vous inquiétez pas là
on va là on va avoir des kumar en ce
sens heureux ça m'amuse
partick auraient givré
regardez j'ai vraiment regarder ça
rassurant mais j'aime a juste eu vous
jetez pièce ça gagne tout seul
en vrai t'as même pas besoin de
réfléchir normalement juste tu étais
pièces et ça gagne tout seul à être papa
soit t'as pas besoin de réfléchir juste
il sortait pièces et tu gagnes en la fin
fléchir déjà b3 c'était pas super bon
moment une double enquête hausse s'est
développée faut juste faire rock et
jouer pour eux quatre déjà même des 4e b
6e 4 était vraiment une possibilité de
prendre le centre géré très détendu
bowie me suis détendu parce qu'il ya 200
points d'écart enfin yaya 600 points l
od car c'est quel format c'est bo bo 2
et du coup ici à un partout sa part en
bo3 le truc c'est que aux échecs en fait
comme ya la possibilité de match nul ça
ne sert à rien de faire trois parties
voilà il ya un pion prend pions prend
est fou des six j'imagine qu'ils
marchent je vais être un coup d'ordi
ouais pas d'ailleurs
des seuils adam prend 17 ans au passage
donc du coup cdc fou prend f3 cavaliers
pros f3 qui on prend fou des six tours 8
français cinq pour être exact sur la
variante je les fait courte mais à la
variante complète c'était ça qui gagne
un pion déjà à yahia il fallait ouvrir
les yeux
bâle et puis on prend ces cinq mais
maintenant il ya cavaliers à 5 c foot
pas faire puis en français 5 m
surtout que je suis sûr que tu comprends
ces cinq gagnantes à ce niveau parce que
très clairement champion français 5a
elle faisait puis on prend ces cinq
dames prend bessette l'ordi
vraiment non mais c'était pour vérifier
l'exactitude de la variante voilà ça va
pas du tout pour les blancs parce qu'il
ya pas eu rock il ya le h4 qui est parti
qui sert pas à grand chose et le cadre
pas dans le bon tempo à sa chope
totalement c'est pas possible
aïe aïe aïe
bon voilà
à l'aller noirs sont mieux placés là
c'est pas possible avec fougue de ses
catastrophiques
c'est catastrophique ok c'est 4 c'est
catastrophique
évidemment il fallait juste francs le
pion aux quatre inquiéter emprise
c'était juste un pion gratuit et en plus
ça dévier le cavalier il y avait qu on
prend des quatre derrière puis on prend
un cavalier prend donc ses quatre dames
ces deux savas harvey sarvi tout d'un
coup on joue beaucoup de bons coups bas
je dirais pas vraiment il y avait pu en
france et 5 qui gagne et une stands tout
à l'heure et là c'est de nouveau très
bien pour les blancs parce qu'il va y
avoir h5 et ça va ça va envoyer
bon là c'est de nouveau complètement
gagnant pour les blancs alors est-ce
qu'il ya cavaliers pros 14.4 d'impro 4
attention il peut y avoir des
découvertes mais au pire cavaliers g5
c'est plus sûr au moins du fait qu'il
prend 1,4 et qui a aidé 6 madame prend
1,4 ça doit marcher aussi un je vois pas
de découverte de toute façon le fouet en
l'air donc il y aura du dame prend
bessette sur n'importe quelle découverte
seul sur cavalia à 5 mais bon
adamou reculer h5n1 qui a valu aux cinq
dames c'est 2
23 jouable aussi la fois 6 il faut
prendre un franc et h5
voilà ça donne des fous ça fait plaisir
juste des petits fous price 3h sinko
5 les robots la prise prise moi je vous
annonce ma tante 3
gagner cinq et on prend et barrages
suite matt vous allez voir ça va être un
instant tu là il ya grand acquis un coup
aussi h5 qui a cavalé f5 qui peut être
chiant mais bon pied on repart avec la
dame c'est plutôt bien joué mais même
dame d2
j'ai quattro et puis on prend d'un match
les cinq noms tu a rigolé tout seul je
suis pas ça me fait marrer en fait c'est
pas pourquoi ça me fait marrer
j'y peux rien c'est incontrôlable en
fait je crois que c'est la compétition
elle même qui me fait mourir de rire
je crois que c'est l'existence du truc
qui me fait mourir de rire ah ouais mais
c'est ça c'est que ça fait trois
semaines que je suis les mecs du top
niveau et là je sais pas je regarde ce
match ça me fait marrer j'ai plus rien
j'y peux rien ça fait marrer c'est plus
fort que moi
jerem celica aux différences à côté la
différence commentaires hilares entre
match et pas vraiment comment commenter
parce qu'en fait c'est c'est terrible il
calcule dit que oui mais c'est ça en
fait je suis sûr qu'ils sont en train de
calculer will power pions prends grand
roque j'écarte machin b5 bi 4 mais en
fait c'est juste que moi je m'attends à
des coups comme cavalier g3 quoi pas à 5
tu vois j'ai même
ça sert j'ai pas ce qui se passe sur g4
damage 6 le retour à la c'est bien joué
francs
ah ça c'est une grosse faute j'ai une
tactique
désolé mais oui c'est un peu la pression
des tournois des machins de commenter du
haut niveau non-stop
je ne peux rien le g quattro alors alors
qu'il fallait faire j'ai quattro direct
en fait pas échangé sa fausse le garde
au dernier moment faire damage 6 après
jouer pour alger au dernier moment parce
que sinon en fait tu laisses la septième
rangée pour défendre à l a pas vu pour
la tactique steak à ypres en d4 prend le
pion est toujours premiers froids
derrière brèche en décompression total
total 47 bon bah du coup faut quatre à
damas
ici bon bah là du coup il a tort bref
trois quand même parce que sur d'arâches
7,3 fuite mais elle va pas
du coup elle va faire tour eiffe sept
cavaliers h4 marché alors la différence
c'est qu'à h 4 on pouvait faire flouer 4
ça prenait pas de matériel mais oui
c'était plus fort parce que ça fermait
la colonne ash ouais c'était sûr qu'elle
verrait pas à tour en f3 du vautour f7
et c'est vraiment dommage d'avoir joué à
gmg puisque ça a permis ce coup tour f 7
ksk
je pense un petit fou et 4 qui va partir
si avec ça je pense va faire foule 4 et
il va jouer pour f4 f5
mais bon faudrait faire un grand roque
quand même un jour mais mon fou 4 il
faut y siens ou tourage 3 mais bon je
pense plutôt fou et 4 parce qu'un jour
tu peux avoir franchi si s'agit d'un
match 8 matt foe 4
ben ahmed
un jouet cd joli coup ça dans ma fuite
stratégiquement c'est pas mal côté nico
tactiquement c'est mieux côté sable et
stratégiquement sais c'est pas mal
allez faire d'un match 4
ouais c'est ça ce que je dis là
dans le chat c'est qu'en fait quand bien
même tu veut mater faire grand que c'est
juste pour amener une tour en jeu en
fait nico joue mieux 200 lots ou pas
f c'est dur de juger dans le chatt tour
h 2 alors ça c'est un peu dommage parce
que ça laisse dame prend h6 bon final un
pion de plus mais elle n'est pas si
clair que ça parce qu'ici un tour eiffe
quattro je pense qui est chiant je vais
mettre leurs vies pour vérifier à tour
fkt f3 heureusement pour f4f trois
mêlées
dirt 3 sarde et sa vallée f3 tourache un
bon voilà kf5 comprend f5 on n'en parle
plus mais c'était sur 800 ça pouvait pas
c'était sûr que ça allait donner un truc
en là c'était obligé en fait c'est
obligatoire bon il a juste fait froid et
sais pas je ne sais pas attention de pas
se prendre tour g1 fait roi de deux
tours h un ton aussi c'est envoyer les
pions failli ces grands moments
c'est marrant parce qu'il fallait mettre
laurent veut du coup ce qu'on est en
finale maintenant il faut aller mieux
pas rock mais bon c est terminé et fayat
rien à voir
non mais c'est ce que je vous disais ce
que j'avais dit à sare il suffit juste
de jouer des coups en fait ça gagne tout
seul tu débrief après alors après je
vais aller me reposer un petit peu les
gars c'est dimanche dès 22h on va aller
on va les pions ces voix-là y attend
tous reproches cet ouvrage suite en
france et 8 où il ya peut-être même un
match qui peut arriver mon avoir médias
vous rêvez de 142 une question de forme
assez classe
il ya trop d'écart il y aura des matches
plus intéressant qui est encore roy et
fuite ou rage suite au rejet 8
ça peut encore défendre un tout petit
peu du coup faut peut-être mieux fait
retour à 7 tours h7 pour ma tv vont tour
à je suis de ça passe aussi tout qui
gagne mais oui il faudra
il faut un autre y'a du rap des matches
qui sont vraiment intéressants avec des
adversaires plus plus coriaces c'est
vraiment une mise en août un calme
c'est quand même beaucoup à ce niveau-là
500 points elo d'écart c'est vraiment
énorme
tours h6 voila voila c'est tout reprend
et tout reprend ses 8500 habitants n'ont
elles et 500 au blitz web angie fille je
crois qu'il est bon à tous niveaux ces
normes 500 points et mais là encore plus
au tout début en fait c'est énorme c'est
pas de la condescendance ni de faut
arrêter c'est pas du tout la
condescendance et puisque je sais pas
trop quoi dire la cei a fixé comme je
disais c'est comme commenter un match
des nouvelles contre quelqu'un qui lie
le retour des six matteau prochain c'est
que n'ont pas dû c'est comme commenter
un match denver contre quelqu'un qui
serait classé 1700 1800 en fait c'est
trop d'écart il ya trop d'écarts
il ya un
car trop trop important en fait entre
1350 par exemple les 1500 il pourrait y
avoir match mais mille trois cent mille
deux cent mille 100 200 300 points elo
c'est encore ça peut encore jouer le
plus simple c'est de notre latour ans
est en fête et poussé le pion à ses
justes ou recettes avec 4,5 à 6 heures
c'était la suite on va
la l'a4
pause c'est ce que je vous disais ça
peut pas ça peut commandes globalement
pas être serrée en fait non c'est un
budget
la creuse
à fait
beaucoup quand même je serai également
400 points ouais c'est ça honnêtement
enfin après le dame b 3 je vous assure
quoi dame b 3e 6 sardes auraient fait
dépenser 5 elle aurait jamais vu pour un
f3 qui avait pris 9,3 et fous des six
alors effet plus on prend ces cinq c'est
quasiment sûr il y aurait eu d'un
premier set c'était réglé en cinq coups
jean réal
la partie aurait pu durer dix coups sa
garde et du suspense suspense qu'il ya
un petit peu rester mais mais ça aurait
pu durer moins longtemps après
le desing coup était bien jeu en fait je
pense qu'elle avait décidé de jouer tous
ces coups là dans l'ouverture mais du
mais pu un peu tourné en fait à ce
moment là il ya eu un gros moment de
flottement genre si elle avait joué des
prend 2,4 alors attaquer le cavaliere
car il était bouger il y aurait eu plus
on prend des 4 puis on prend des quatre
cavaliers prend des quatre dames d un
tour c'est 8 et là c'était un peu la
cata
qui
elle m'a écrit
cj gars drôle
je vais déjà écrit
moi
l'arrêt
allah
avant les messages sont fantastiques
ah bah oui ça c'est normal
abba
conseils que j'ai donné
on sait que je vois
c'est vraiment jouer un coup en fait le
conseil
coup et ça va gagner tout ça
un juste pas s'inquiéter en fait faut
juste pas y penser et puis ça va gagner
tout seul
ça gagne tout seul généralement ce genre
de partie faut pas trop y penser en fait
quelque part plus tu y penses plus tu
vas te mettre en danger en fait là quand
il ya une telle une telle différence
quand t'as pas trop l'habitude
imaginons travail
à notre niveau enfin ça dépend mais là
il faut pas trop se prendre la tête
il suffit
tranquillement ne pas se mettre la
pression et ça va gagner tout seul n'a
pas
pailla pas stresser en fait allez on
veut le match retour
non
paniquée contre des joueurs plus forts
parce que je stream après non sifflé
après f4 alors là j'écouterai nji long
de 4,5
allez sicilienne quand même et c'est
dommage de ne pas avoir pris le centre
h3 c'est sympathique s'empêche rouge et
4 on va voir ce que ça donne
alors au lieu de lui apprendre des
pièges dans y'a pas de piège à l'égard
juste ça aurait été mieux de mettre le
puits en d5 parce qu'il y avait le
centre
faut juste pas y penser cavaliers c6 v6
ou g7
on contrôle la grande diagonale qu'est
ce que c'est que ça comprend rien
je comprends rien lassé c'est
là et c'est pas si idiot en fait la fin
il se trouve que ce qu'elle joue c'est
pas si idiot parce que les noirs ont pas
pris le centre kevrenn
ça peut se jouer il faudrait faire des
cinq coups des six dames c'est 7,5 et on
en parle plus mais ça ne va pas faire la
des cinq coups des six dames c'est cette
tu développes b6 fou bessette gros rock
5 c'est la prépa
ça y est les rock one
à 6 c'est terrible
dijoux le plan de la sirène sans
réfléchir à ce qui se passe en face la
tran l'aca réfléchit pas du tout à ce
qui se joue en face là c'est terrible
il a vu jouer les coups de la nage des
enfants fait l on voit
elle est complètement génial ni qu ils
petit rock qui part dans l' attaque tout
à l'heure c'est génial on a par ok là on
part dans les pieds adverses mais bon
c'est pas grave c'est quand même bien
joué parce qu'il ya pas d attaque du
tout le fou j'ai 2 mais bon il faut
faire gaffe le fou j'ai deux il peut
taper mais je vous tous tempo quoi l on
voit tout tempo
c'est extraordinaire j'ai pas comment
pas donner des pièces en lin tellement
elle joue tempo qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
car elle
j'ai trois cavaliers h5 ça peut être
dangereux bon ça va elle part en d2 ça
aurait pu être dangereux dans les chais
tôt et je pensais qu'elle donnerait plus
vite du matériel en étant
tactiquement et j'aurais bien ouais
parce qu'elle développe bien ces pièces
en plastique un hockey
un bon coup ça c'est bien
par de sardes
mais ça va
c'est sûr mais je vous des coûts
tellement responsable vite eu quatre
genres pourquoi pas c'est pas mal joué
c'est bien
elle a vraiment des bons comment dire
ce cargo
rires elle a un bon instant mais en vrai
un très bon instant
elle a une bonne tête chf la dir est
madeleine à paris vous passez à de
lancer un appel à in touch va faire fou
prend effet qu'à toutes ces pièces
doivent être développés bien placé là in
touch
non mais toutes ces pièces sont bien
placés là tout d'un coup ça n'a pas pris
le centre rapine assez rapidement
une tâche à va
la blague je suis un fils de
départagerait ludwig
c'est génial ben joue tout tempo quoi
c'est génial seront jouées un coup voilà
cavalli b6 qui a aidé cinq ans même ce
serait cool qui est candidat c'est
génial d'aller peut-être fois ci ce qui
invalide v6 allez tous à 7 qui avaient
des systèmes pour dent mais c'est
incroyable ça envoie tout thème pourquoi
barbecue mais c'est pas possible je veux
pas être 500 en fait je peux pas envoyer
que des coups comme ça tempo quoi si
génial je suis tout est ses fantasmes
non mais en vrai ça dit roland peuvent
et quai jusqu'à va doubler si ce qui est
français vite dame prend aux pas fou
prend pas donné les fous contre les
cavaliers
elle est bien là c'était fraîcheur fois
tout à une fois il y aura que des bons
coups tempo c'est génial j'en peux plus
je n'en peux plus
désolé les mecs je peux pas empêcher de
rire là y'a un joli truc c'est qu'un
valeo 5 pour un peu s'en sortir qui
apprend qu'il prend pour prend pour
prendre tout reprendre des 4es dame
prend 1,5
mais ça va pas ça va pas être vu ses
enfants elle a le temps de réfléchir oui
mais bon elle joue quand même super vite
je vous quasiment à ma vitesse en fait
ge qui craque complètement c'est
terrible c'est bizarre qu'elle je t'aime
pour je peux ajouter tout le temps tempo
élevé peut-être du bullet d'habitude
elle s'en fout peut-être
raciste qui veut qu'à valider quatre
jours
alors on voit tout tempo c'est
extraordinaire il faut prendre plus vite
la sarde à l'écaillé des quatre tuque
pour ce piège alors ça c'est moi qui
l'ait mis à l'elac y avait des cadres
comme il faut le voir il va faire [ __ ]
quatre cavaliers 2 qui avait pris un f4
allez on termine cette games sas elle
fait cavalier secal jpp en fait aller
quand même mon sarde
ca fait caillasser cas
bien joué un qui est déjà une toupie
sekkat c'est super bien joué j'ai donc
fait et alès bat non mais
ce qu'elle joue si bien que j'ai vu 800
je viens peut jouer ça n'avait pas l'air
d'être très fort et puis là franchement
ils jouent bien à
ah ça troll tour prend des six est bon
à terme quand il suffisait de jouer
allez pas
béchir je m'attendais plus à ça en terme
de niveau de jeu
maintenant elle a un bon feeling après
tactiquement ça va vraiment rien quand
même un bon feeling
bah ouais
en tête
torje 6 quand même une petite dame
j'ai quatre ans j'ai cinq dames pranger
cinq cavaliers f3 qui avait plongé cinq
abandons et sur h4h 6
avec pour commencer avec un peu de
chance ces rois h un fou bessette et
c'est terminé
voilà c'est tout reprend j'ai deux
foulées 7 est prise à 8
et ben voilà ça gagne tout seul j'avais
annoncé à l'est et sur allait pas
stresser un âge où tout empower
elle joue tempo
rfo h1 c'est bien joué menace d'alger de
maths à oui mais c'est est sûre il faut
pas se presser j'étais sûr qu'il
gagnerait jamais aucune pression pour ce
match j'avais zéro doute pour ce match
un petit cavalier 6 haye adam prend pas
à mesdames première dame gdf cavani m6
vêtements ce qui est marrant section
g3 et cave a lieu deux échecs fourchette
est sûre d'alger cinq pieds carrés des
f3 fourchette
oh là non cela me fait peur c'est fait
cavalier cissé adams et 8
change tout et gagne la finale je
déteste ce genre de truc où tu peux te
faire mater
aussi on en est
fait peur
ça fait peur à tout le monde allez dan
des 4 allez juste dam des catés changé
d'âme c'est fini allez juste dam des
quatre notre hall d'amd 4 c'est fini
hfr carré lieu cinq dames sévit depuis
ce temps je le sente choc-là juste dam
des quatre échanges les dames c'est pas
possible
adam eux deux et d'un projet 4 voilà
ah oui peut jouer là nul d'ailleurs
pleutre éclairé ouais mais voilà j'ai 6
h 5
et voilà
cash 4h trop gentil fils adam et c'est
gagné au bon moment allez h4h 3 voilà en
plus ya plus de problème de temps vous
qui bouge
il va faire le matin non ils troll c'est
pas possible d'être en lui comme ça mais
c'est au non c'est pas possible d'avoir
autant 3 j'en veux plus nancy fait 45
j'arrête tout et perdre 4 5 épreuves
cinq bons
assez aideront à l'arrivée voir wave 3 g
ii roi proche de mais c'est drôle ça va
aller si elle joue
h2o est l'espion prend hydro c'est le
stress les gars quand ça stresse sat
choc
c'est bien joué car éléphants aussi
aller la forêt un petit cavalier ou
trois échecs au nom car il y eu trois
échecs c'était joli cavale et prendre
trois pions 3 3 ça gagner
épreuve 3 céderont
on va
elle trouve en tout cas c'est gagner
dans tous les cas c'est gagné puisque
quoiqu'il arrive sarde va faire nul au
pire ici enfin au pirée au mieux puisque
le prochain cru racaille prend pions
mais il va avoir gagne un ennemi à 1,2
me comme quoi bon essayer tout à l'heure
en finale c'est gagné
trop peu plus à bages comprend un bon
bah c'est gagné
c'est gagné gifi va être vraiment forêt
zikara qui
pardon je l'aurais et aiderait qui
trollent
bon
nier
il joue il est très serré c'est ça
le mal c'était marrant
afin de
ouais ouais ouais non clairement c'est
plus mental de toute façon la côte
chosun
on
on fait quoi on envoie un petit raid
chez sarnoff pour l'interview avec avec
le stream américains et on se retrouve
demain pour de nouvelles aventures
allez on va faire ça au moins on peut
suivre l'interview en sang je pense que
ça va être marrant je pense que ça peut
être
non je pense a peut être fait
merci à tous d'avoir suivi on se
retrouve on se retrouve devant ciao ciao